as governor of texas what can you do
with the federal government acting as
the way it is like what what are some
i i you you look at the 10th amendment
and you assert your power as a sovereign
state
you look at those two clauses that i
just mentioned in the constitution you
have a full mobilization in
your national guard you start to tax the
remittances that are coming out of texas
you know with illegal immigrants and
that's how you build a border
security fund you also designate those
cartels as criminal and terrorist
organizations
so you go after their the the banks that
are you know funneling and laundering
their money you go after these stash
houses you go out to real estate agents
and agencies
and the banks that are supporting these
stash houses this
this is an intricate system that you've
got to peel the layers of the onion back
but the most important thing you've got
to go after was resource and the other
thing is
you've got to stop with the magnets if
you come into texas you're not getting
free taxpayer benefits in texas you're
not getting in-state tuition as illegal
in texas and so it's those type of
things that we have to use as a physical
deterrent
and then also economic deterrence um
what kind of resistance would you
foresee from the federal government
uh the federal government just and see
that's a great point
because see that comes back to exactly
what we said republicans always put
themselves in a box that says well
we've got to get the permission from the
federal government it was free and
independent states that created
the federal government and so when you
understand federalism
when you understand your duty as as a
sovereign state
you don't sit back and you wait for the
mother may i from the federal government
you have a duty and responsibility as a
governor to protect the citizens in your
state
and right now the citizens of the state
of texas are not being protected i know
everyone's saying well we're going to
build a wall
there's 1200 miles that we share with a
foreign nation
there's only 145 miles of wall that's
been built
how long do you think it's going to take
us to build another 1055 miles
of a border wall which the trump
administration estimated
at 10 to 12 billion dollars and we've
only said that we're going to
allocate 250 million well to be fair i
heard a story
that trump actually proposed uh moats
full of alligators
that was actually reported
clearly trump no the headline exactly
exactly they said
somebody somewhere made a claim that
trump wanted moats full of alligators
and that's actually more expensive
digging a trench and filling with water
and alligators
feed those alligators plus the rio
grande is already there it's already
there
i mean you already have a physical you
know
barrier a border a river but if you're
not putting anyone down there as a
physical
deterrent then it's just a crossing
point
and so you get to watch as you know on
our website the video
of guys just fearing people across these
videos are crazy
i've you watched someone we've had a lot
of reporters we've had on this show have
been down there
and it's the most insane thing to see a
residential neighborhood and then also
you'll see 15 dudes just run
full speed and then like border guards
chasing after them
high-speed car chases uh carjackings
have have increased
uh ransacking of grocery stores and
convenience stores these are the type of
these aren't asylum seekers what uh uh
i believe this is i'm getting this right
but um do you know the most dangerous
cities in mexico and where they are
it's right along the border yep just
just south of the us border you
have right now going on and this is
going to explode pretty soon
there is a cartel internal turf battle
turf war
and these guys are gearing up uh because
there are certain cartels that want to
expand the drug trade fentanyl and what
have you
there are certain cartels that are only
in the human and sex uh trafficking
and there are certain cartels want to
bring all that together under their
control
there are some incredible videos that
show some of the massacres and so how
some of these bodies
are just laying out in the streets all
over the place you can go down and you
can be on
our side of the board you can hear the
gunshots it reminds me
iraq afghanistan you can see the flashes
this is what's happening just on the
other side
and i guarantee you if they are having
an internal border
uh fight wow between the cartels on the
south side of the border
that's going to spill over to our
southern border and there there are
people who have houses just like right
there
right there right right on the border
they live in terror every day i mean
think about this in
if you know that a cartel member is
going to come up to you and say
if you say something we'll kill you
my first i thought would be to move my
first thought would be
where you're going to go yeah who's
going to buy your house i don't know
i mean that would be my that would be my
my life's goal at that point would be
first
head down don't say anything that gets
me killed and then second
this is america and and just imagine
okay this is no different from isis and
the taliban
operating and we're allowing them free
reign and free control
of our border control how do we stop it
well hold on what do you think would
happen
if one of these guys in these houses
took a weapon saw one of these cartel
members and fired on him
killed him what do you think would
happen oh you know what's going to
happen was he armed
was it an armed person how do you know
he was a cartel member what have you
and that's why i said we have got to uh
designate them
as a criminal and terrorist organization
and if you are working with the cartels
that's a failing offense you're going to
jail you ain't going to see daylight
didn't uh what was it fast and furious
weren't they working with
obama's administration was working with
cartels to run guns
into the the us well i mean let's be
yeah absolutely
because what they wanted and and uh
brian terry the border patrol agent lost
his life
because of that gun around this game now
of course if you say fast and furious to
most millennials out there they're going
to think of ven diesel yeah how
convenient yeah
okay good job government yeah they
wanted to
they wanted to track the weapons how
they were moving and they
gave weapons i i almost just don't
believe they were that stupid
let's give guns to all these people
that'll help us stop them
no that's what they do with isis but
what they really wanted to do
was they wanted to say that we've got a
gun problem in the united states of
america
because we have straw dealers that are
selling guns not the government we're
going to try to create the straw man
and say the gun distributors and
manufacturers doing it
and then we can therefore shut down the
gun manufacturing industry here in the
united states of america but look
uh what obama administration did with
fafsa fears was the exact same thing the
obama administration was doing in the
middle east
within syria and then also in libya i
mean the whole thing that happened in
benghazi
was because we were trying to negotiate
and get weapons back
from the folks that we had supported
islamic jihadists against gaddafi and
we're going to send those weapons
into uh into syria yeah the u.s has a
problem with kind of doing that you know
mujahideen for instance
oh yeah yeah we don't have a good track
record of picking
hussein's bath party we disbanded the
bath party and then they all became
al qaeda basically or was it isis i
don't remember at first it was the uh
fedeen
and then it became al qaeda in iraq
i was there and then isis isis came when
you create a void much the same as we
are doing now in afghanistan
uh if you create a void basic law of
physics someone's gonna fill that void
and so if you had just left a residual
force kind of like a strike force to
keep the other side at bay not worrying
about
democratic institutions or what have you
and so isis came in
uh and we knew about it as a matter of
fact uh al baghdadi was once in our
custody there and he was released
and was that under obama yes amazing
it seems like obama didn't really have
the uh desire to end
isis uh he didn't have the desire to do
anything yeah
and joe biden is stepping in and doing
the exact same thing and so you're going
to see an incredible bloodbath in
afghanistan just as you saw in iraq just
the same as you saw in vietnam remember
the killing fields of pole pot
oh yeah okay exact same thing's going to
happen i've already had a couple of my
former interpreter translators in
afghanistan
ask me for letters of recommendation so
they can get out but you know what's the
interesting thing
they could probably get to the united
states of america quicker if they could
pay to go down to brazil
and come up you know through our poorer
southern border than to try to go to the
embassy and get them to do the right
thing for these young men and young
women who helped us
as interpreters and translators and
getting them out of afghanistan
they are truly under attack and they
will be killed
by the taliban by isis or whoever comes
back into power and guess who also is
moving into afghanistan now that we have
precipitously left
china oh i've heard that china has taken
over the melton road initiative yeah but
trump wanted to leave earlier trump's
initial deadline was may and
biden pushed it back a little bit yeah
but see the thing is that anyone will
tell you
all you have to do is leave a small
residual force to keep the other side at
bay leave a small special forces
uh type of force that can make sure that
they'll come in and
once again reestablish the sanctuary i
think you know we had we had sean
parnell on the show and that's
ultimately
where we came to where he was saying we
can't stay there forever
the united states can't just be sitting
in this country but a small team
something to do exactly what you're
saying absolutely i mean we're not
talking about leaving a large
million-man force like we did
in germany for what 50 or 60 years but
if you leave
you know the quick strike force like i
say with the special operators
that can go and target certain key
individuals and keep the other side of
bait that's all you need
it's mistakes after mistakes you know we
shouldn't have been in there in the
first place
for a lot of reasons well you know the
thing is we had to go in initially but
what happens is that you lose focus you
become
an army of occupation instead of army
that is
enemy oriented and you go in you start
worrying about building roads building
institutions and all those things
that's not what you're there for you're
supposed to find bad guys and kill bad
guys that's all that's needed
and now where are they going syria who
the bad guys no no no the
you know biden's moving troops who knows
who knows i don't think he knows i agree
and i i don't think that the resource i
don't think the
the administration is going to be too
focused on helping americans
i think it's it's going to be more of
what we see with many other presidents
focusing on foreign policy and kind of
disregarding what americans need in this
country notably of course
our own border security seems to be a
mess and
they're well it's just the same as the
pipeline you know joe biden comes in and
shuts down oil and gas production in
pipelines being in alaska being keystone
being at fracking in texas but yeah he
says to vladimir putin
yeah go right ahead start stream too
absolutely we'll we'll
we'll track the sanctions on nordstrom 2
build your pipeline yeah uh
as for us in the u.s we'll shut them
down and it's remarkable because they're
putting pressure on a pipeline in
michigan that goes to canada canada is
outraged over what they're doing
absolutely it's it's
it's we're breaking contracts with them
and it's remarkable that we had
the the the the the crisis we had in
texas with the the freezing
oh man if we can talk about that oh yeah
but but you also have the colonial
pipeline hack
yes now is not the time to be hurting
american energy independence no it's not
the time to be heard in america
never is really no it's not and now it's
not the time to be talking about the
green new deal and all of these type of
things
because what happened in texas was that
26
of our energy distribution plan was in
wind and solar about 23
wind 3 in solar and what happened when i
mean we knew this was coming 10 days out
well the wind turbines froze and the
solar panels froze over
and so all of a sudden what was supposed
to be 26 of your energy distribution
plan dropped down to 3
and there was no backup because no one
had done any winterization checks on a
lot of the natural gas plants and we had
shut down a lot of the coal
fire plants which we can look at clean
coal uh
to to be burned out there that that was
the big failure was they didn't do
winterization they didn't do the
winterization no
maintenance checks and services and you
know what my bet is just my opinion
i haven't looked into it but i'm willing
about climate change the people who are
building that uh
those wind turbines were probably like
we don't need to worry about
freezing this is texas climate never
changes well we're good
yeah well and the other thing is that we
heavily subsidize
yeah those those systems and uh look in
the free market system if you want to be
a reliable energy source stand up on
your own
yeah you know i'm a big fan of wind
solar but we don't have the
technological uh um
we don't have the efficiency for one not
yet to go as big as they're going now
some countries have gone really really
big with wind
but people don't understand is that you
have to subsidize a lot of it um
or you have to get energy elsewhere
because there's not always wind
you know what i mean and the challenge
is batteries transportation
and so it's it's not so simple and one
of the things um there was somebody who
posted this on facebook they were like
uh they said something ridiculous like
the reason we won't get of the
the reason we're not getting rid of
fossil fuels is because
the democrats and the republicans are
beholden to massive corporations
and they just want to make money and i
responded with the real reason we're not
getting rid of fossil fuels is that the
energy returned on energy invested for
everything else except for nuclear
doesn't provide enough energy
the amount of energy going into these
systems that are like that's not
petroleum
save nuclear isn't enough and the other
thing is that even with the the
green systems the the wind and the solar
guess what you use to push it through
the system
natural gas and you know it's you know
people really don't understand
how much petroleum is used to pro
to build solar and wind and also in this
and all the all the plastics
petrochemicals yeah it takes a lot of
petroleum
to even build and so the question i'm
asking people is look i
love the idea of renewable energies
geothermal tidal energy over here of
tidal energy yeah
there's different ways to utilize that
is reliable the tide tide comes in tide
goes out
and you capture some of that energy the
problem is how much petroleum do you use
to build those systems
and how long will it take to pay back
and offset that carbon
and will you actually produce enough in
the long run will the device last long
enough and a lot of circumstances the
answer is
no producing solar for instance not
necessarily efficient enough right now
there's a lot of cool things we've done
with mirrors on those salt water vets to
produce steam energy there's smart
things we're doing
but it's not good but they're blocking
nuclear power yeah it's like you've got
a clean solution with a massive energy
return and they're like nah not that one
because you know they don't care about
the climate
they care about power absolutely and
control yep
that's it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you